it's gonna be hot up to sixty million
Americans will be uncomfortably hot
today and millions more could face
severe thunderstorms heat alerts are up
along the East Coast the south and the
southwest to where it's expected to feel
like 100 degrees or more over widespread
area and in Pennsylvania severe storms
like this microburst caught on video
caused serious damage over the weekend a
falling tree at a Swim Club north of
Philadelphia injured seven children and
two adults yesterday Don Dahler is at
the dolphin swim club in feasterville
Pennsylvania Don how are those injured
folks doing good morning well nine
people in total went to the hospital two
with head injuries one with a back
injury and as you said it all happened
here yesterday at this Swim Club near
Philadelphia when part of a tree fell on
a tent
the nine people injured were taking
cover under a pavilion tent when
lightning hit a large tree nearby
sending it crashing down on top of them
severe weather event must have came
through the park numerous trees are down
lifeguards help get people out from
under the tent before emergency
responders arrive just minutes later
firefighters cut the tree apart to make
sure no one else was trapped underneath
Ruben Diaz his girlfriend was carrying
his one-year-old son when she was hit by
the branches and fell to the ground he's
been crying I could totally hurts you
know extreme weather hit a wide swath of
the country all weekend this lightning
storm in Kansas forced drivers to pull
off the road as winds hit over 60 miles
an hour about a hundred miles away
strong gusts toppled some 140 train cars
the derailment blocked over a mile of
track further east in Pennsylvania a
microburst tore through the town of
Lawrenceville toppling trees and
knocking out power for hundreds of
customers two buildings were damaged
including one owned by Jimmy Cohen I'm
shocked I mean I'm totally shocked winds
also took down trees in Wisconsin I
never seen anything like this as
lightning cracked through the trunk of
this tree in Illinois I know I was
really bright and all you saw you saw
was a cloud of white smoke back at the
Swim Club some of those victims were
actually trapped under that tree for
quite a while because it was so heavy
and as for Ruben Diaz his girlfriend
well he says she is still in the
hospital as of yesterday afternoon with
back injuries and he says it's just a
miracle that no one was more seriously
injured yeah miracle indeed Don thank
you very much